Joyeux anniversaire, Filou !
Joyeux anniversaire !
*souffle*
*applaudissements* Bravo !
26 ans ! Ça nous rajeunit pas tout ça, hein ?
Ah, joyeux anniversaire mon pote ! Je t'ai pris ton gâteau comme t'aimes bien, là.
Bon bah, merci beaucoup d'être là, qui veut du gâteau ?
Moi moi moi !
Et mamie aussi veut du gâteau.
En plus j'ai rien mangé depuis trois jour là, j'me suis tapé une gastro !
Je vais chercher les petites cuillères.
Je vous épargne les détails mais quand j'allais aux chiottes...
Oui merci Nicolas, merci.
Au fait, vous avez vu la vidéo sur YouTube que je vous ai envoyé par mail ?
On a vu ça, nous ?
Bah oui, je te l'ai montré ! C'est les vacances de Félix et Pauline !
Merci !
Ah !
Ah oui ! C'est toi qui a fait la vidéo tout seul ? C'est bien fait.
Ouais bon, c'est pas non plus...
- C'est quoi Toutoube ?
- Tiens.
Ouais, elle est pas mal, on peut avoir du gâteau ?
Et vous avez lu le commentaire qui était posté en dessous ?
Ouais j'ai vu !
- On a vu ça nous ?
- Euh, c'est quoi ce commentaire ?
"Cette vidéo c'est de la merde. J'ai perdu trois minutes de ma vie."
Qui est-ce qui écrit une saloperie pareille ?
Laisse tomber papa, on sait pas qui c'est.
C'est Toutoube qui a dit ça ?
Ce ... Ce merdeux est gonflé, en plus il dit même pas qui il est !
Y a partout des commentaires comme ça.
Ah bon ? Ben alors c'est n'importe quoi alors, Internet !
Félix, le prend pas pour toi, elle est très très bien ta vidéo.
J'suis sûre qu'il pensait pas ce qu'il dit.
"Et je pense totalement ce que je dit."
*rire*
J'dois appuyer où pour voir Toutoube ?
Ce ... Ce petit merdeux, là, si je l'attrape !
Félix ! Y'a rien de grave !
Des commentaires comme ça sur Internet, y'en a plein, hein. Ton frère te l'a dit.
Ouais, enfin surtout sur les vidéos de merde...
Bon, te prend pas la tête.
De toute façon nous le principal c'est qu'on ait aimé la vidéo donc on célèbre, et on mange le gâteau !
Bah oui c'est vrai Félix, te prend pas la tête, profite de ton anniversaire !
D'accord donc, je fais comme si de rien n'était, au fait !
Voilà ! C'est pas un p'tit con qui va t'empêcher de fêter ton anniversaire !
J'oublie le commentaire !
Voilà ! Maintenant le gâteau.
J'oublie aussi le fait que... Cette vidéo est en privé.
Et que seuls ceux présent dans cette pièce ...
Ont pu voir et commenter la vidéo.
Thomas, pourquoi tu écris des conneries pareilles ?!
Mais c'est pas moi ! J'suis le plus jeune ici donc je dois insulter tout le monde, c'est ça ?!
On se calme, on se ...
Si ça ce trouve, c'est toi ! Ou c'est maman même, hein ?
T'as pas honte de dire ça ?
Bon c'est toi, Nicolas !
Mais pas du tout, moi j'ai trouvé très bien sa vidéo, là ! Faut arrêter !
Mamie... Tu crois que j'aillais pas te cramer sous tes petits airs, espèce de sssss...
T'es sérieux ?
Salut ... Sss ... Ça va ? Ça va, ça va ! J'ai du mal à me concentrer, j'ai faim !
Filou, il doit y avoir une erreur, on a pas pu laisser un commentaire comme ça. C'est pas notre genre.
C'est marrant, c'est ce que disent exactement ceux laissent ce genre de commentaire.
Thomas ! Tu ...Tu vas nous laisser tranquilles un peu ?!
Bon alors !
Quelqu'un a laissé son ordinateur allumé avec d'autres personnes autour.
Et c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui a mis un commentaire sur l'ordinateur de la personne qui avait laissé l'ordinateur allumé.
Ah bah voilà ! Ça c'est possible ! Hein ?
Techniquement...
C'est p...
C'est possible.
Ah bah tu vois, Filou ! Tout s'explique ! C'était pas nous.
D'accord... Au fait c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui a utilisé votre ordinateur pour laisser un commentaire, c'est ça ?
Voilà ! Non mais faut pas dramatiser comme ça.
Allez, essaye de passer un bon anniversaire, et après, on cherchera qui c'est.
Donc... Vous ... Vous n'y êtes pour rien.
Voilà ! Donc on peut fêter ça en mangeant le gâteau ! Allez Filou !
Pourquoi vous m'appelez Filou, au fait ?
Oh ! C'est ton surnom !
J'ai toujours trouvé ça ridicule perso.
- Mais non non, c'est pas ridicule !
- Ah si si si.
Y'a que nous qui t'appelons comme ça donc c'est pas grave !
C'est notre petit Filou !
C'est notre petit Filou ! *grrrrr*
"Va crever Filou."
Qui a écrit ces conneries ?!
Mais arrêtez de me regarder comme ça !
Donc l'un d'entre vous a fait ça, et vous voulez me rejeter la faute ?
Bien, bravo la famille ! Applaudis toi ! Bien, la famille ! Super ! Génial ! Vous m'énervez !
Ça peut être que toi, Nicolas.
Hop hop hop hop ... Déjà on va se calmer d'un ton avec moi, là.
Pardon ?
Moi tu sais pas où j'ai grandi, ma biche.
- Oh oh oh !
- Baisse le ton, là !
Non, je rigolais au fait parce que je peux pas ...
C'est mon meilleur ami, pourquoi j'aurais fait une chose pareille ?
Ouais. C'est pas Nico, c'est sûr.
Ah !
Il sait pas écrire sans faire de fautes d'orthographe.
Voilà !
Et c'est lui qui à ramené le gâteau, d'ailleurs.
Non mais t'est vraiment con toi.
Non mais ça va pas ? Qu'est-ce qu'il te prend ?
Tu dis parfois n'importe quoi quand t'es énervé, peut être que t'aurais pu écrire...
Non mais vous êtes vraiment tous des malades, hein ! Faut vous faire soigner  !
Thomas !
Mais c'est pas moi !
C'est toi !
C'est forcément l'un d'entre nous, mais ce n'est pas moi !!
Oh, ça marche !
J'avais même pas vu ce commentaire !
Donc, ça veut dire que c'est peut-être moi !
Bah qui d'autre ?
J'hallucine.
*souffle*
Ça marche !
J'y crois pas !
C'est moi !
C'est moi qui ai posté ce commentaire.
Je sais même pas pourquoi.
Y'a longtemps, j'avais aussi posté une vidéo sur YouTube et on m'avait insulté.
Hier, je passe une journée de merde, j'rentre et tu me parles de ta vidéo, tout sourire.
Mais j'savais pas qu'elle était en privé.
Je voulais peut-être ...
Te rendre moins heureux pour me sentir mieux ?
Le pire c'est qu'elle est pas si mal, ta vidéo.
J'me suis jamais sentie aussi lâche de toute ma vie.
Je regrette tellement, j'suis morte de honte !
J'suis désolée.
Hé hé, mais quelle histoire !
Des fois, sous couvert d'anonymat, on fait des choses qu'on ferait pas dans la vrai vie.
C'est vrai.
Mais il faut pardonner.
C'est bien quand ça se termine.
Bon Filou, je propose qu'on passe à autre chose ?
Y a quand même un anniversaire à fêter, là, non ?
Qui veut du gâteau ?
Ah ! Moi !
Et mamie aussi veut du gâteau !
Mamie, elle en veut !
Juste avant, une petite question, est-ce que vous savez qui a commenté :
"Ouais t'as trop raison."
Thomas !
Non, ça va pas ?! Non ! Ça n'a jamais été moi !
- Non !
- Tais toi !